what's goody Hopper at the verse welcome
back to Hot Breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros I am your
host comedian Joel Byers and we have
done over 400 interviews with comedians
on this show so subscribe to our YouTube
channel and wherever your favorite
podcasting app is because we're dope and
our guest today is dope his comedy
career started in third grade stealing
jokes from a magician but the comedy
grind really started while in college
where he then took it to Detroit where
he was part-time comedian part-time
teacher part-time spin instructor all
while doing glamorous shows like run
down houses in the very glamorous
Detroit but after posting a prank of his
students online getting 20 million views
overnight he ends up on Ellen and now he
is here on hot breath so please welcome
to the show The One and Only Joe
Dombrowski we love a host who does his
homework let's go look at that hit the
nail on the head also as a listener of
hot wrath it is kind of crazy hearing
you say what's goody in person
that's a little wild thank you so much
for sure I appreciate your kind words
about the show I sure didn't realize you
were a listener I am listening well I
also I'm a big reader too so I'm
currently reading yes I can say that by
Judy Gold and I'm also did you read it I
haven't but I'm familiar with Judy yeah
super great and then also
um the new comedy Bible by Judy Carter
have you read that one I haven't no I
always God I'm such a teacher I cannot
let this side of me go I just feel like
you can't you can always be really good
at what you do but you can always get
better so I'm constantly like reading
rereading soaking up comedy stuff and I
listen to her breath all the time wow
that's so oh I'm honored I love it thank
you you love it even 12 years into
comedy you're still a student like me so
I love that yeah oh my God I mean like
let me make sure this is on too I'll
always have goals
you know yeah so what are your goals now
I'm about to shoot us my first special
uh-huh so that's some a goal that I've
had for a very long time that that's
about to happen so that's cool
I still have I I won't say smaller but I
have these goals that are kind of like
the comedian notches that might not mean
anything but we all sort of want still
like I my one of my bigger goals for
2023 is I want to do a late night set
like I just want it like is it going to
move the needle probably not but I want
it like I just want to feel it and yeah
know that I did that as a comic
um and then like pitching around a few
shows that I wrote but you got a pilot
about your life no no I actually am
going a different route like I'm not the
teacher no at one time you did right at
one time I did and I still do have that
in my backpack all right but I um I'm
working with an unscripted concept that
I put together oh Loosely so no one
steals it right and you don't have to
you don't have to say whatever you don't
want because people are well people are
savages I um yeah it's Loosely I will
say following the lives of teachers
outside of teaching oh cool unscripted
lots of humor that naturally just brings
itself up but that like getting that
sold is another big big goal for me I
don't know if that one will be in 2023
the big one for 23 shooting the special
getting the special hopefully sold and
out there best worst case scenario goes
on YouTube which in this day and age is
a comic is a great
place to do it for sure and then
um yeah hopefully Landing late night and
then we'll go from there we'll see what
happens yeah I do I am curious of like
almost what's next it seems like a lot
of people are doing YouTube specials so
my brain is already like well I wonder
what's going to be the next
iteration is it like kind of what
Schultz and now Dane Cook has done of
selling it themselves and then recouping
the expenses that way or like or is
YouTube like it's still the way and it's
still a way to get a bunch of exposure
and it's all you know at an expense but
you sell tickets which you can then
recoup as well right I think honestly I
think the model is going to be
very Krista Stefano with
like shorter YouTube specials more we're
going to see much more half hours and
less hours and then the other half like
you still shot it and you can do
whatever you want with it so like he put
his out the rest of it was on YouTube or
personally sold or I don't remember
exactly what he did but I kind of feel
like the industry is going to stop with
this long-form content being the big
names and the big money because like
let's be real who's who's sitting down
for an hour right exactly like like we
are because we're comedy psychos but
like who is I put three minute videos
out and I watch the drop off their
attention is less than halfway right
it's like okay so what's really
happening here I don't know so so I am
still actually still toying around I'm
gonna film my hour but I don't know if
I'm going to release the hour yeah I
might do it like 30 minutes instead I
don't know yeah when I when I did mine
like I self-produced one and I sell it
on my website and like I shot a bunch of
behind the scenes footage like the idea
was for it to be a documentary yeah and
then you get into post and you're like
oh this is this is another year of
editing did you post yourself
um I did it with the guy that okay cool
because I do know how to edit so we were
like going like back and forth yeah nice
nice it's yeah it's a whole other I I
have there's the projects live or die in
post really oh God I know I'm so scared
well my whole thing too is I'm taking
baby steps like right now I have all the
jokes that I want I figured out which
ones I want to take out I know what
jokes I'm going to film so now I'm
tweaking a little bit tightening
refining just microscopic things like a
word here or there of course and then it
will be ready after I shoot it I will
decide
like what how are we going to do this
what to do with it but is it is this one
are you are you putting up the expenses
up front I am oh my God I know I'm
self-financing and then we're gonna try
and sell it and if no one buys it then
I'll put it out myself so we'll see
but the internet's the wave now it I
mean that's how that's how everyone
what's so cool about it is like you can
build a specific audience and then just
live on that audience there's no like I
want all of America it's like what's
unique about me who else can relate to
that and then you can build an audience
around it yeah and I definitely did so
this special too as you mentioned I was
a elementary teacher for a long time and
this special is going to be all of my
teaching material yeah so it's it's
thematically about and it's not a
teacher show it's not a show for
teachers it's a show about one teacher
and his crazy life doing that so it is
specific and Niche in the fact that a
lot of it has to do with teaching and a
teacher but I did change my jokes to be
very general so that everybody has a
seat so you like everybody's gonna
understand what I'm talking about you
know just to really like maximize on
that because my biggest fear is that
people won't buy it because they're like
yeah it's too specific yeah and but it's
funny I think which is it's it's tough
when people blow up on social media
sometimes it's so early in their career
that they don't have the performance to
back up this audience that they've built
and the worst thing about people blowing
up on social media is people go see them
live and then they're like oh I got my
photo but they weren't really funny so I
won't be back type deal right you've
been doing it 12 years so you're you're
ready for this right and I will say that
that was my so when I blew up I had been
in the game for like seven years so I
had some chops to back it up but like
seven years like you remember being
seven years in like like I watched my
dude I thought I was the [__]
I watched my sets back and I'm like you
piece of [__] that had no punchline get
out get off I hate it I've like taking
stuff down from back then because I'm
like don't let anybody see this it was
growing but whatever like it was my it
was my launch however
being at where I'm at now I do really
feel like I'm ready for for that I'm
ready to like truly put it out there I
did what I did and and it's great so
what does that feel like you're you're
like a grinding comedian you're a
teacher you post this skit overnight
it's 20 million views yeah you like wake
up and your life is the same person one
literally not not an exaggeration woke
up and that was the first day I was
recognized in the streets like it was
game over you're and I remember saying
to myself your life has changed the rest
of your life at the end yeah the end and
were you in bed like did you roll over
and pull up your phone and look or did
you know what so I the day that I posted
the video
I really didn't think anything of it
which kind of shows you that like
content like yeah put your best foot
forward but like
[__] can do great I posted this video
with terrible lighting I threw it on the
internet at the worst time it was like
nine o'clock in the morning something
like that I shot it on my phone with no
extra camera equipment didn't edit it
didn't caption it and just pressed
post that's it and it went nuts so I
post it in the morning I work the rest
of the day I'm not really paying
attention to it and then I had dinner
plans with a friend of mine and we were
out
at dinner had a normal dinner and I left
and another friend of mine was calling
me from Tennessee who I hadn't seen in
like seven years right and I'm like this
is weird I should answer this she's like
you're on the news
in Tennessee I'm in Michigan I'm like
what are you talking about she's like
you're video is on my TV right now I'm
like this is nuts so then I go to the
video and I'm like watching it
I had my phone down and I'm just like
it's not stop like my phone's not
shutting the screen is staying bright
like I'm losing battery because it's
just notifications notifications people
texting me people calling me and then we
both went back to my house had a drink
and just put my phone on my coffee table
had a drink and we're just watching it
like holy [__] and we were going back
and forth and we're like so what is what
we're like what is viral like what are
we gonna what okay we'll say ten
thousand maybe hit 10 000 right there in
that conversation we're like okay okay
50 Maybe 50.
hit it and she's like if you wake up
and there's a hundred thousand or more
we'll call that Viral book of a twenty
twenty twenty million 20 million I walk
into school the next day
everybody knows about it nobody even had
to say or talk like
wild
the parents oh my God like I'm I'm
taking the kids out at the end of the
day they all are looking at me like holy
[__] like it was a thing dude it was a
thing my kids my students were getting
phone calls from radio stations to do
interviews about me
that's how nutty it was that's a little
creepy a little creepy yeah for sure but
also like it was because
I wasn't so high demand they can't get
all of me so they're like who else can
we get to talk about him the kids boom
yep and then how soon after that did
Ellen happen uh about oh okay so let's
see that about a week so I posted the
video in the end of that week I went on
a family
reunion vacation in Orlando and there
were a lot of kids on this
um trip with us like cousins kids and
things and we were at um
Epcot and we all went on the Finding
Nemo ride which is voiced by Dory which
is voiced by Ellen Degeneres and we're
going in the ride and the whole weekend
people are like I wonder if Ellen's
gonna call you wonder if Oprah is going
to call you I wonder if Dr Phil and I
was like yeah yeah I don't know so we
get on the ride and I'm like wouldn't
that be so crazy if Ellen like actually
did call
and we got off and I had a missed call
from Los Angeles and it was the show and
then
did my first interview
on the streets of Epcot
went back to the hotel had to do a zoom
then they wanted to do one final zoom
and I had to coordinate with Disney
World to like give me a a quiet space to
do it and I was in like a woman's like
breastfeeding like like area and I did
the zoom in there didn't hear from them
for like a week I was like I didn't get
it whatever they called me when I got
home from work one day just got done
teaching and they're like okay we are
gonna book your flight you're gonna
shoot the show tomorrow
oh my gosh
I know so I go and I do the show and
[Music]
um
eat
was surreal right like all these people
know who you are everybody's like oh my
God so funny now the thing about the
show they
very much made it clear to me we are
painting a picture of you
wholesome fourth grade teacher
accident
went viral let's talk about it right and
I was like for sure I don't even care
like let's just do like let's see what
happens go they're like we know you're a
comic straight up said to me this isn't
your Last Comic Standing By that Shen so
don't try and be funny just be yourself
and I was like
that's what got me here oh yeah hello so
I go and I do it and um
they were they also said to me they go
hey yo if Alan
you know in commercial breaks or
whatever gets up and fixes her hair
grabs coffee or has to touch up her
makeup don't be offended that she's not
like staying there to chat like this is
her job she's got a lot to do I was like
whatever no big deal
we filmed the first bit also you don't
meet her until that moment until you
walk out I thought she was gonna like
come in the dressing room and be like
hey great to meet you I'm so excited to
do the show see you out there no like
that's like we've learned since then
backstage you can be a little colder
well so you think right not my
experience so I get on stage we film and
the first take is the longest and she
um so okay we're going to cut to a
commercial break and I'm preparing for
her to leave
she cuts to commercial she turns to me
she goes hey I heard you're a comic and
I was like yeah and she goes well you're
really funny and I was like oh thanks
you know thank you and she goes I don't
think you're hearing me she goes I think
you're really funny you need to do
something with that and I was like oh uh
and then boom we're filming again I
couldn't even wrap my head around it but
I've never forgotten that and that's
what
like pushed me to like take it to the
next level so when I got home
I was like okay people know who I am now
let's go for it so I start cold calling
clubs to see if they'll let me headline
outside of Michigan and some clubs did
some clubs did it built a small little
tour for myself and then uh it just took
off that I did LA my managers and agents
came to the show liked what I did signed
me
queer career career
like now you can do what you've always
wanted to do and what's funny is you had
a superintendent that told you not to do
the show right 100 told me not to do the
show before Alan even called he's like
you're not to do the Ellen DeGeneres
show or any other media that calls
because a lot of sources were making the
mistake of calling the school first I'm
like oh baby this ain't about them this
ain't about them uh but Alan when they
called me they called me directly and I
was like yes I'm doing this I do not
care I don't care yeah I don't care what
do you think I'm gonna say no because
your superintendent are you kidding me
or you think I'm gonna say no
get out of here your principal was
supportive right
yeah oh well you had a principal who in
Detroit that supported comedy grind your
comedy grind okay so at this point I had
worked in two different
elementary schools two completely
different districts okay and my first
principal
um we started doing comedy it started to
I built a little bit of a local name for
myself the parents started coming to my
shows that scared the hell out of me
then the staff started coming to my
shows and then my principal came to one
of my shows one time I was like so
nervous and then she came into my
um classroom the Monday after the show
that she saw and she shut the door
behind her and I thought I was gonna get
a scolding and she's like no you are
very funny I love what you do and you
need to push forward with that and go
for it and I was like are you kidding me
so then if I she would turn an eye
anytime I had to take like a or like
leave half day on Friday I do get to a
gig or or take a Monday off because I
was doing a Sunday show wow look what
she would just go for it and she was
like whatever well I'm like we'll make
it work and I was like holy [__] holy
[__] yeah
yeah that's amazing the principle of the
school that I worked at when the video
went viral he was like he came he comes
in my office my office
my office
he comes in my classroom and he was all
like well just so you know you shot that
video in here so that's property of the
district I'm like yeah yeah
20 million yeah yeah that's mine bro
time to capitalize you don't pay me
enough to care about whatever you're
saying so how about that no no no no I
very much do my own thing yeah yeah that
and that's my mom uh is a teacher stop
it yes yes she's a teacher and so I
understand like the life of a teacher
verse in the classroom and outside the
classroom and balancing that and
everything and I actually talked to her
on the way here because I was like I
wonder if she has a question for you
does she and her her question was who
she she's always curious about who the
teacher is that like is like the spark
for successful people you know is there
a teacher for you that was like oh this
is the person that really gave me that
nudge to like become my like best self
oh for sure and I think the the biggest
misconception with me is that I that I
don't like teaching that I'm just making
fun of it loved it wonderful career and
the I loved working with the kids I
hated the parents politics paperwork and
poop but everything else like was it's a
great job
and yes I don't think I would have gone
into teaching if I didn't have my third
grade teacher so I went to a private
Catholic School kindergarten first and
second grade
um and then a brand new public school
was literally built in our backyard and
I was the first class to attend that
school and my my third grade teacher
Miss Renee badalamente was so
she was like
I don't even know how old she was at the
time but she was like a younger teacher
she was full of life she brought 100
herself into the classroom she was a
vegetarian she was super into like
Cheryl Crow the 90s you know she and she
wore like bell bottoms and like cool
cool stuff she was just being who she is
and my mom said that when I entered
third grade on that first day of school
she says that it's like The Wizard of Oz
where it's all black and white and then
like all of a sudden the movie's in
color she's like when you went to that
first day of school you came back and
your world was in color she let me
learn
in the style of creativity like if I
didn't if I If instead of giving a
retelling of a book if I wanted to act
it out she let me act it out in front of
the whole class like she let me be a
goofball and express that she she
challenged me to do the talent show and
in third grade I did my first stand-up
set as a stand-up comment for the third
grade talent show and she was like go
for it boy and then I did and like that
kind of set that spark too and just I
always kept that in my back pocket when
I was a teacher too like my little
weirdos were always my favorite so I was
like do your thing little weirdo I don't
care what it is like be your authentic
cool ass self and uh yeah she inspired
the hell out of me to just be who I am
yeah and teachers need I don't know I
have some I went to school with some
teachers that are people that are
teachers now and I'm like oh that
explains our education system yeah with
some of these people that are now
teachers but it's like it's tough what
the pay is and the pressure and the
responsibility for what the pay is it's
like I don't I mean and you were
Innovative like you taught with like
YouTube and you were thinking of
different ways to really get through to
this like younger generation that's
growing up in The Matrix essentially
yeah yeah like what what what what what
can we do are we doomed yeah what's the
solution 100 doomed or 100
do you want to know why
we're totally we're so duped
it it's not unrecoverable though okay
but if you think about it
oh God here we go in this country
we
reward people
um for going into these businesses that
make more money right and if you if you
work for one of those types of jobs you
will make more money for yourself by
making more money for this company and
this business and that's not the case
for teaching which is insane to me
because those companies are selling a
product right so the more product you
make the more money the people who work
for that product make as teachers the
product is kids and kids are humans but
yet the people who are taking care of
those humans are making literal peasant
scraps to the point where they have to
work second or third jobs just to live
and provide and and to get through life
they have all this extra stress on their
back and you expect them to go in as
their absolute best self and provide for
these kids
uninhibitably every single day uh no
that's not the case we need programs in
this country to reward teachers for
choosing that job and maybe it's not
um paying them more because that's
coming from taxes it's probably going to
be really hard to to find those fundings
right but why aren't teachers getting
cutbacks why do teachers have insane
student loans why don't teachers why do
teachers still have to pay 500 600 a
year just to get their certificate
renewed wow to be able to teach give
them give them that piece of paper so
they can spend the money and maybe make
a car payment or something like to make
their lives easier and then on top of
that
no shade but we have this program called
Teach for America in this country which
is great in theory uh-huh
but we're taking undergraduate
college students
and without even any education
background at all most of them don't
even major in education we're putting
them in the worst schools in America
why
they should be in the areas where
there's very little issues and the
teachers who are teaching in these worst
schools should have experience and
should be compensated for gaining that
experience so they can focus on these
kids because they now know what they
need you know just the system's broken
and corrupt but I don't think it's
beyond repair I think the country just
needs to get creative I'm a comic with a
message [__]
mic drop mic drop I do like to say that
I use my comedy like my comedy is just a
vessel for change right like I want you
to laugh yeah at my show and then I want
you to leave in question while you're
laughing and why you're laughing is
because
of how insane it is to be a modern
American teacher yeah there's got to be
parallels between being a teacher and a
comedian if
are you serious it's the same thing
uh-huh is it
you're nine to five you're dealing with
um kids who are acting like drunk adults
and then you're you're five to nine
you're dealing with drunk adults who act
like kids it's the same thing oh I first
of all I do pride myself in my crowd
work I really do my crowd work is what
it is because I was an elementary school
teacher that's all it is you like they
serve you something you gotta dish it
back and it just it just translates to
Stage it's great it's great yeah I guess
that is what I've learned is I've I'm 34
now and I knew we were around the same
age yeah you know white don't crack and
um especially in Atlanta right
we outcha and um yeah in Atlanta I'm my
boy Joel like I came up in all the hood
rooms like those are the only shows I
could book back also I just want
everyone to know today that
um I asked Joel if he wanted me to pick
him up a coffee I'm I'm breaking the
wall I'm sorry oh no you're good and he
said no and I said are you Mormon has
Joseph has the sweetest little Mormon
face I love that I love it it well it
was 4 P.M Joe you know I I'm me not
drinking coffee at four I mean because
I'd like to sleep oh right and you flew
in today you flew in a day early to do
this I just want and I appreciate that
yeah well you know I'm not trying to
miss the gigs baby white boy Joel that's
awesome yeah that's awesome similar
symbol or uh like upcoming Detroit very
very
um very Urban which is a weird term but
yeah it's like uh Detroit's a black City
Atlanta is a predominantly black City
and coming up in comedy like you gotta
be able to
um work all different types of crowds
and you the way to do that is not be
scared just because now people can laugh
at everything it doesn't matter who the
audience is just be who you are and do
your thing and someone's gonna connect
to it yeah that's what I've learned is
like authenticity will Bridge all gaps
like regardless of background or what
their experience is where you're coming
from like if you're being real then you
can really entertain anyone yeah and as
long as it's funny well yes funny it's
got to be funny don't be a big hit don't
yes gotta be funny don't think if you
say it cool that it's you know that it's
funny yeah there's got to be punch lines
kids 100 I gotta remember it's comedy do
you know how many people
like just get out there and don't punch
post punch lines I'm gonna show you a
clip after this I'm because I'm not I'm
not gonna publicly talk [__] we're gonna
do it they'll be patreon yeah someone
posted this clip like a bigger comic
recently and I was
baffled baffled they were also using
this clip to promote their shows that
are coming up and I was like okay first
of all there's no punch line and second
of all this joke is just
wrong it's just like it's just mean wow
and if there's if there was a punch line
that joke was salvageable but it was
just a mean-spirited joke and was like
posted it with full confidence like and
at the end it was like here's where I'm
at next going to my shows I was like
it was wild it was truly wild that and
that just reminded me I forgot your hot
breath water hold on oh there you go oh
my gosh thank you thank you I forgot oh
I'm keeping it yeah that's for you I'm
keeping this it's the coolest water for
the hottest podcast there we go oh thank
you yeah I love it I love it you're
welcome yeah this and this is uh font is
water they're mountain spring water in
uh the Blue Ridge Mountains of Georgia
so this is real this is good water this
isn't that Dasani poison it's right
there's one ingredient and it's Spring
Water Dasani has like four ingredients
and none of its water that's weird yes
well I learned something new today that
there's mountains in Georgia yes yes
we're claimed to be good at we are
actually Okay cool so we're still we're
still are you still good on you just
gonna do a little bit more here oh you
tell me when okay okay I'm good so let's
get into you being like a comedian now
and this is your full-time job like I
think something I get asked a lot is
like taking that leap like that moment
to where it's like okay I'm willing to
take the risk and make this completely
unstable job my career it was was the
moment the 20 million views was the
moment let me make this amount of money
in comedy first like okay how did you
decide first of all how long were you
and your wife together before you just
went full-time comedy
she I went full time
hmm I was full-time before she moved
down here oh she moved down here for you
we went we went to school together in
Tennessee okay and then we were like
friends and then we like kept in touch
after we graduated and we visited and
then we're like oh we should like do
this thing do this so then she moved
down here
and I was full time when she moved out
all right okay but I was probably eight
years in I think oh okay so I don't
think that you had this experience so
my partner Morgan
first of all you got to get you a
partner who like sees the vision and is
like down to right 100 yeah like if your
person is I'm so sorry if your person's
holding you back from this
you you have to choose and if it's not
comedy hey that was your choice but like
if your person doesn't believe in what
you're doing
it's not gonna I don't think it will
work I agree because you'll hold
yourself back from opportunities and
you'll say no to things and Morgan
is a a math analytics just very solid
man financially and both like in his
career in his career path which I'll
tell you what it is later I don't like
to say it publicly is is linear like you
work and then you do this thing and then
you work and then you get this thing and
that's how his job is right so when we
were when we started dating yes I was a
comic he was coming to shows but we
weren't really sure if this was ever
going to be like a full-time thing as
much as it was just going to be like
something that had some side income for
me although we knew that it was
something that I would want and would
take we weren't just sure if it was
gonna really take off and when it did
we really had to talk about like what
does this look like what are what are
the goals here and when do we know it's
not working like what what's the sign
that it's not working and we just really
like
blew through these caps and were like
okay well comedy now makes this much and
I make this much as a teacher and then
once I started to
make when when comedy was making more
money than teaching it was a good sign
when comedy was sustainably making more
money that teaching it was a great sign
and when comedy doubled and then tripled
what I was making as a teacher it was
like okay you have enough money to
support for at least a year let's see
what happens in that year and then I
left and it was
we both saw the benefits which was when
I did leave the kicker was I had a um I
think there's a red thing on your screen
that means it's recording oh good great
yeah yeah we're good um thanks for
looking though that's ADHD no you're
great I I have to look I'll get roasted
in the YouTube comments because they're
like stop looking in the camera and I
was like I'm literally making sure it's
still on yeah it's not about you
comments
I'm I'm one-man band here
sorry for putting this up for free sorry
I had a uh I was a good teacher troll
like I was a really good teacher like I
really cared and my last year was really
tough I had a tough group of kids with a
lot of baggage and I was also trying to
balance teaching and uh growing my
comedy career and in teaching you have
to go through evaluations every single
year and like everything you do you
should strive for the best right
the highest evaluation ranking in
teaching is called highly effective and
I at the end of the year did not get
highly effective I got one notch below
that which is still really good but I
was I'm a little bit of a perfectionist
sometimes that kind of like bothered me
so I had a meeting with my boss and she
was like yo I'm gonna be straight up
with you do I think you're a great
teacher she's like I think you're good I
think you're good do I think you're a
great comic because well I haven't seen
your act but I would assume that you're
pretty good and she goes I think you
have the potential to be great at one of
these things if you leave one of these
things and one of these things you have
a degree for and you can always come
back to and one of these things I think
you need to strike the nail while it's
hot and that's right now and I think you
know what you need to do and I was like
yeah this is the time
this is the time and I was pissed a
little bit at first because I was like
is she telling me to quit like like does
she not believe in what I'm doing and
then I was like what a gift for a for a
boss to not bash your dreams but to tell
you you're splitting time between two
things and you can only get great at one
when you give it all you've got and I
was like holy [__] and I needed to hear
that and I went back and I told Morgan
and he was like
Let's Do It Let's Ride doggy let's do it
we did and we did and it was the best
decision I ever made but it took a lot
of thought it wasn't just on faith it
was like all right well let's look
through this I'm making this amount of
money what do I need to make and then
for how long like you I think a lot of
times people see whatever their like
passion is oh it's a leap of faith but
like really making sure it's well
thought out we'll make that leap of
faith sustainable 100 which is why when
the video blew up I finished that school
year and taught two full school years
after that because I
number one needed steady reliable income
and that was my career number two I knew
that I was riding this teacher thing and
I was building this teacher audience and
I wanted to remain relevant as long as I
could and that was it and then what she
said mixed with the fact that I was
realizing that I wasn't giving the kids
my all
nailed it home and I was like this is
the time and this is what I got to do
and and let's do it and it's scary as
hell but every comic you do it like you
you there's a point yes that you do it
and it's so scary but you figure it out
and you work on your craft and you get
better and you just go go go go yeah for
me it was like I saved up a nest egg
um Enterprise Rent-A-Car oh come on the
only good thing they did come on washing
cars in a time there we go that was a
rough job the elite though of car rental
you know one might say we were the elite
well I don't want to perjure myself you
know they may book me for corporate gigs
yeah and I'll take a sponsorship yeah I
would actually love a partnership as
well if you guys yeah actually I should
tap into that I love Enterprise it was
great but uh word of green worked that
for a while and then like I saved from a
nest egg and then like made like a pro
con list of like well what's the Worst
That Could Happen what's the best that
could happen like just quitting my job
and I was willing to live with the worst
and it just kind of it worked out but
it's like when you when comedy becomes
your job
you've it's it needs to be a well
thought out decision because it can
really suck the fun out of it when it
becomes like oh I don't get to do this
gig it's like oh I have to do this gig
or I have to find this gig it like what
was a fun hobby is now like your
livelihood and it changes the
relationship with comedy that year that
I quit too I said no to literally
nothing like people would even be like
we will pay you 100 for 45 minutes and a
little after thing too and I'm like sure
like I don't know what money is not
gonna come in so how could I say no to
something and would just just rack up
the coins as much as I could yeah and
like you said having a supportive
teammate to really be there for it
literally is the best you can't you
can't yeah you really can't I mean even
you like we were talking before this of
like pandemic we're unemployed overnight
you had just come back from like a
Canadian and Australian tour like yeah
you're Global and all of a sudden you're
like oh I'm unemployed did Australia did
Canada I'm in Edmonton Alberta doing it
was for blowout sellouts right and I'm
watching every single show
less audience less audience I'm like I
sold all four of these shows out and
then by my last show they're 25 of the
house had people in it and we were like
okay [__] things are getting real
flew home when I landed they closed the
Border literally I wasn't even home yet
my flight landed and they closed the
Border that's I was almost stranded in
Canada
and when I got home
my managers called me and they're like
every single show on your tour has been
canceled and it was like
20 something cities gone wow like all
that income gone I had nothing
and I surprisingly didn't panic I just
got creative and the one thing that I
did is I create I I was like let's Flex
the muscle a little bit I'm not a
character actor I'm not a character
comic I created a character her name was
Trish she's a white trash addict
who her job is to shuck pearls on
Facebook live have you ever seen people
do that in real life people shuck pearls
on Facebook live and then you can like
buy them and like for people do that for
real I was like well let's do this as
comedy
but I turned it in a trivia
so I was playing trivia with my fans as
this character and if you got the answer
right I'd Chuck you a pearl which is now
not only catering to my fans but people
are coming to this Pearl shucking thing
thinking that it's real and I've still
made people who are fans from that who
come to shows they'll be like I found
you because of trash her name was Trish
and it was all about just like getting
creative because I think especially in
comedy if you let people tell you what
it is and what it is not you lose
yeah you gotta follow your instincts
yeah yeah and I've interviewed several
social media people on here and just
saying that have built the following on
social media and be able to monetize it
I know there can be like you can make a
good living just from home and creating
videos you know I mean people are making
well have you heard of country Wayne
before yeah yeah I've never seen him
live yeah he recently was talking about
making I mean six figures a month from
just
shoot me yeah that's crazy okay honestly
here's my thing it's like I know I could
do that if I wanted to but like I thrive
in the realm of Life performance I don't
know it's like yeah I was thinking about
that the other day and I was like if I
double down on my internet [__] I
wouldn't have to go out and I'm like but
like I don't know like the Roar of a
crowd is my black guitar heroine you
know yeah there's nothing like it yeah
but a nice juicy bank account is all
terrible isn't it but the live shows can
do that as well yeah they can so it's
just one one can feed the other you know
and the one can be your day job the
social media yeah
I plan on quadrupling on my social media
stuff when we have kids okay so I can
really focus on like being home but
still making a lot of money in comedy
yeah but like not right now I'm just
doing what I love so you're that thought
out that like at this moment in my
career I want to be focusing on this and
then the next chapter I'm going to be
doing like another thing like are you
that planned out yeah kinda yeah like I
know I know once we have kids I probably
won't tour for at least six months and
I'll double down on my podcasting my
videos my online content continue to
generate revenue from views and also
from sponsorships but then
um while I'm in that phase of Life I'll
be writing all new material about having
kids and then take it out on the road
wow I'm psychotic I'm such a teacher oh
my God I hate myself no no words of
affirmation positivity oh my God I
literally okay here's another funny
story my um
my team we're like building my 2023
touring schedule and they're like okay
let us know when you want to work when
you don't and what cities you want to do
I sent them a color-coded spreadsheet
that's amazing I know because I was just
like I need you to know and like I need
you to like not [__] it up so Kate said
I want you to book me around blue don't
book me on dates that are red and here's
the cities that I haven't played here
are the cities that historically do well
for me let's make it happen oh you did
their job for them a little bit
wow but as much as I pride myself in
being type B A little type A just creeps
up in my butthole every now and then but
I talked to Ben Brainerd on here and he
did the same thing he he popped during
the pandemic on social media doing like
States yeah yeah I know Ben is yeah yeah
so he he built a huge following doing
that and he was come out his tour and
how he built it out and then just
basically hand it to his manager and
like here's your job basically make it
happen yeah exactly it is crazy going
back a little bit you talked about how
building an audience and how like if
you're not good they won't they'll get
the picture and not come back and that
was my biggest fear when I took my
comedy out of Detroit is how are people
going to respond to this I've never done
this before and the biggest affirmation
for me is the fact that I did a show in
Boston at a bar
then I did a weekend at laughs Boston
blew it out and in two weeks I'm doing
two sold out shows at the Wilbur like
they're coming back right but it's stuff
like that that like that's the
affirmation as a comic like not only do
they like it they're coming for more you
know so you got to pay attention to
those little things as a comic too
because you've got to know like are they
into it yeah I mean this is your first
time performing in Atlanta and you're at
center stage where like Jim Brewer is
there tonight Roy Wood Jr shot his
Comedy Central special there like oh
that's where he shot it it's better
stage isn't it crazy how they can change
things so much yeah I interviewed him
the next morning at six oh shut up
that's cool it was cool for him like
that was another moment of like oh this
podcast is working like he was willing
after doing two Comedy Central tapings
to get up at 6am and do a like a podcast
before he flew out like that like
getting to do things like this
and to meet successful people in the
game you're like oh like the nice people
are like they're successful for a reason
because like they're nice and willing to
give back even no matter how big they
get yeah that's cool that's really cool
I love I love seeing where people shoot
their specials too because it's like oh
God you never know like Rosa Baker shot
her Comedy Central at Zanies watch a
special back you never know oh I didn't
know that it's Nashville you'd never
know oh yeah
Pat shutters there too you know she she
shot hers at a comedy club here but you
could never tell
um Roy Scoville shot his at like in the
basement of a church yeah but here it
was like um it was relapse theater but
um they put up curtains like you could
never tell that you were in like what
was once a homeless shelter you know
they're a crazy ass story
yes
I was supposed to film my special in
three weeks from today uh-huh and I had
this whole Vision I'm doing all my it's
on my the bangers about being a teacher
and I had it all lined up that I was
going to shoot in the the gym of the
first school that ever hired me as a
teacher right school's 120 years old
a month ago the ceiling fell through oh
collapsed like
destroyed the building the kids don't
even go to school there anymore they're
gonna say the kids they're all dead
no thank God it happened on a weekend
funny It Happened One classroom over
from my classroom oh man so uh yeah
that's cool they don't even know if
they're gonna open it next year so
they're like clearly you're not shooting
your special here and I was like oh [__]
and then it picking up the pieces to try
to get a venue on that specific date
that's not only of quality but is what
you want is very hard so that didn't
happen so now I'm filming in LA in March
which is cool because I've kind of
changed a little bit I'm going to
theater rather than a school yeah but
it's kind of like it's I was like God
damn that would have been cool is that
whatever place you could do it though no
it's other schools well okay here's the
thing
we then started looking at other schools
and we started looking at other schools
in other states and everything like that
and I was like just not
into it because it didn't hold the same
weight I I thought it would be cool to
do some behind the scenes [__] where I
would walk around the building and be
like this was my old classroom this is
where I used to steal hot lunch like you
know stuff like this is where a hawk ate
our class pet rabbit true story like
that would be what I was going to do for
the behind the scenes stuff and just
going into a different school it's like
this is a school but it's not mine it
just doesn't
resonate with mean if it doesn't
resonate with the artist how does it
resonate with the audience so I just was
like
yeah if it's not the vision anymore so
let's see we see what we see but now we
have three more months to work on it and
three more months to get abs again so oh
abs and 30s okay the dream is alive
we're trying whoa I'm not gonna look
like a frumpy ass looking [__]
it must oh Joel I'm gay I have to look
great come on babe what do you do what
do you do I'd like to get abs yeah I'm
frail well apparently they told me that
abs are made in the kitchen which for me
that was gonna be very cake is made in
the kitchen as well
and so are things like Nashville hot
chicken like you know so I don't know
that it's gonna happen but I work out
like three times a week I have a trainer
in Seattle
um but then I like go on the road and
just eat the local Cuisine that's the
thing yeah the road yeah what do you
normally eat to like stay healthy like
what's your food anything I'm a garbage
disposal yeah oh I mean I grew up as a
husky kid like anything oh really it's
still in there when I like see the
cereal out I'm like a husky Joe husky
Joel and we try we gotta keep it
together you know
I've always been like I was probably
when I was 20 I was probably a buck 50.
and 6'3 how tall are you six four six
four yeah
um
but yeah no that's not I can I have the
ability to eat a lot of things and not
keep it on me but now in your 30s that
is slowly not becoming the case anymore
and everything on the road is hard
Comedy Club food is [__] garbage it's
all fried it's all [__] garbage yeah it
is we're trying yeah nothing makes
people excited to laugh like the itis
you know God I know or like uh some like
boneless buffalo wings that are just
drenched in Frank's Red Hot it's like oh
God yeah and on a Friday night late
night show shoot me
as we land This Plane I ask everyone
this and you may know what I'm about to
ask because you've listened to the show
but it's your worst bombing story yep
the worst gig something like what is
what's that low for you this is not the
worst but it's uh important moment in my
career and I
had a joke that was um
the premise of it was that I used to
help out with special ed Special
Olympics when I was a teacher and the
premise of it was that was the first
time that I played Sports and I was good
at it the joke is about me because I'm
gay right it's good it's good
it's good
but I love you still it's good the joke
works all right I'm I'll double down on
that [__] yeah but
I'm on a lineup and the guy before me
goes up
has crippling cerebral palsy and is just
like talking about it and he's first of
all he's killing and then I went up
there and the whole time I'm like are
you gonna say it
I did it I didn't say it because I
started to really realize that there is
a difference like yeah people are coming
for Comics left and right right I'm
first of all I'm not trying to get that
type of backlash too
and I was like this joke could be funny
but it's not ready yet because it's
still a little too targeted and one of
the things that I like about my comedy
is yeah I can get edgy but I'm not
coming for groups of people I'm coming
for people like it doesn't matter what
you are I need you to like look at the
joke and be like that applies to all
Races all demographics all disability
like all every it's just a it's a people
trait rather than this and I couldn't do
that joke and I just
got off stage and I tried to perfect it
and I was like if you couldn't do the
joke don't do the joke and I never have
and I don't think I ever will unless I
can craft it in a better way but um it
was a moment in my career where I was
more conscious of what I was going up
with rather than just being like I have
a premise let's try it of course and I
bombed because I was super in my head
and didn't say that joke which then
ruined the entire direction of my set so
uh yeah then you do a show in like a
rundown house in Detroit run down house
baby you talking about the show The
Rundown house where the green room was a
homeless man's living quarter surrounded
by surrounded by piss bottle his piss
bottles
that's coming up in Detroit okay that's
what that is okay God oh my God and then
I was I took all my [__] on stage with
me too I remember that Mike I'm looking
with this homeless man just rifle
through my bags what are we doing here
that was the moment where I was like you
are a starving artist with a job but
that's why I like talking bringing up
those moments on here because people
just see a comedian at one level of
success but to get there I don't think
people understand the reality of
pursuing comedy as a career oh everyone
has these stories you're like an adult
sharing a hotel room with another adult
on the room on on the road in some
sketchy ass motel in some City you've
never been to just like super weird I
remember I did a gig where I had like a
a string of little corporates and I went
with these guys who I never really had
ever met and the whole time we were
there it was just sketchy weird ass [__]
after weird ass [__] and I'm just like
trying to make it right I'm just trying
to make it then like afterwards talking
to people with other show here follow me
here find me here come to my stuff yeah
it's like you do the weirdest [__]
sometimes but even then you were pushing
it like even then you were still mindful
of like promotion and being like me like
yeah check me out let's keep in and
touch you weren't like just phoning it
in you were willing to still commit
biggest mistake that Comics make I feel
also I don't feel like I'm an expert in
this field so I'm just telling you from
my personal experience but I think the
biggest mistake the comics make is they
don't tell people
like what's what's next for you and
where to find you
comic [__] on other Comics sometimes who
end their sets by saying follow me at
but if you don't say it and they liked
you how the [__] are they gonna find you
baby like come on like this is we're not
going on Carson anymore okay like they
gotta find you online and then they
gotta see what your dates are coming up
so they can come back like tell them
where to find you and that was something
that I always did I would stand at shows
and then they would say oh we're gonna
follow you and it's like give me your
phone I'll do it I'll do it hell yeah
one we're we're going we're gaining a
follower today you know yeah exactly
[__] around yeah well speaking of which
where can people follow you and keep up
with you great Segway you can find me uh
my social media handle is Mr D times
three mrd t-a-m-e-s the number three
that's everything Instagram tick tock
but you have millions of followers but
it's that
my God the children the children I don't
know what the Tide Pods did to those
brain cells but like the children
the children Instagram Facebook Twitter
all of it Mr D times three which I'm in
this weird phase too I want to just go
by Joe Dombrowski but I like have used
this Mr D times three thing for so long
long story we'll do it next time
um find me there my website's Mr D
times3.com go there for all my tour
dates going back on the road in 2023
um and a ton left in 2022 find me there
would love to have you and listen to the
social studies podcast if you're down
well beautiful well before we get out of
here is there anything else you want the
world to know uh thanks for having me of
course and like do you want the world to
know this is just the beginning see you
soon